here's a nice puzzle a town wants to  enclose a square plot of land with posts  if the posts are spaced one meter apart  then there will be 150 posts too few if  the posts are spaced three meters apart  then there will be 70 posts too many how  many posts does the town have  let's work it out let P be the number of  posts and let D be the distance in  meters if the pulse are spaced one meter  apart the distance will be P then there  will be 150 posts too few so that will  be equal to D minus 150. If instead the  posts are spaced three meters apart the  distance will be 3p then there will be  70 posts too many so that will be D plus  70 times 3 because the posts are spaced  three meters apart that means 3p is  equal to D Plus 210. now let's flip  these two equations and subtract the  second one from the first canceling out  the D variables we get 2p is equal to  210 minus a negative 150 which means 2p  is equal to 360. so p is equal to 180.  the town has 180 posts